hello everyone as I said in my previous
video over the weekend I played two
tournament games in classical time
control and it was it was the crazy
regional championship sort of like
qualifications for the Croatia team
finals and since I didn't know who my
opponent was gonna be in the first game
nor do I have the black or the white
pieces I didn't really prepare you know
I
we just came there we had our coffee and
you know we checked out for who our
opponents were so my opponent in the
first round of was international master
from Bosnia Muhammad boric and you know
as I didn't prepare I didn't really you
know what to expect it was just you know
here here here's your board you know
play some chess so let's see how it went
and you know didn't really have any
remarks about my game I didn't really
make any mistakes but as you'll see in
the game at playing passively can be
just as great of a mistake as actually
making some blender or a mistake when
you face an international master so he
pleaded d4 I play Knight to f6 Knight to
f3
I go went for g6 and Bishop to g5 he
goes for the Tauri attack I went for the
bishop immediately nice to e4 he played
Bishop to h4 and Bishop to g7 III I
cancelled he played Bishop to d3 I
defended the Knight d5 c4 and here I
played c6 I didn't really like this c6
move but I thought it was pretty solid I
didn't want to rush anything or push too
hard you know I just wanted to see what
he would do so he castled and here I
played Knights to a6 in positions like
this usually I would go for h6 and g5
but I don't know something about this
game didn't didn't feel right about
doing this although this is a perfectly
reasonable idea simply h6 and after he
develops I can push g5 but should be
three captures captures and then decide
either to capture on c4 or go for Bishop
to e6 but okay in this game I play
tonight to a6 and I play this move with
the idea that
okay I'm threatening night before his
Bishop 23 doesn't really have any
retreat squares he could go to see too
but then I can also capture it so if he
allows this he would either have to
capture on e4 which doesn't seem likely
or he would have to retreat to e2 which
is the last active square for the bishop
and you know I don't I don't mind
playing a move to get his Bishop to a
less active square but sorry I thought
that he would play something like a3 I
would go Knight the c7 gain more control
of the d5 square and then maybe push on
the Queen side who knows depending on
what he plays but here he played C
captures on b5 i played ck after 75 and
he went Queen to b3 so I didn't really
like the idea of going Knight the c7 now
so instead I played Queen to d6 I
thought it was a thought it was a very
active square for the Queen I didn't
really see anything wrong with it I
don't mind a bishop to G to reassure to
g3 I can always simply move the Queen
and his bishop is pretty useful on h4 at
the moment as it is eyeing my e7 pawn
that still hasn't advanced the e6 and
he's kind of preventing the rook from
coming to to d8 as then I can't even put
push e 6 so I didn't think he would go
for Bishop to g3 he went Knight to c3
and now
ok now maybe maybe I should worry about
something like Bishop to g3 followed by
Knight b5 first capturing but yeah it's
it's not not really likely as if if he
captures my knight then I capture B
characters on a6 he can no longer go
night b5 but and again if he goes night
before than Bishop to g3 my knight on a6
is guarding the c7 square so I didn't
really worry about this much I played
Knight captures on c3 he played B
captors on c3 and here I finally went
east 6 I he played rook F to c1 and rook
F to c1 is a of course a natural move
either preparing c4 or the rook will be
very useful on the C file if it ever
opens and here I really thought about a
lot of things and
I thought about how I could develop I
mean I can never go back to b7 to c6 if
I could do this I'd be alright but my b7
point would be hanging and I couldn't
really find any reasonable ideas about
how to develop here so after some I
don't know maybe even 20 minutes of
considering disposition
I played Knight back to be eight so this
is this looks a bit weird but my knight
really isn't doing anything on a6 so I
thought I play Knight to b8
interestingly this is the engines
favorite move so very happy about that
but actually when I played this move I
was already down to maybe like 20
minutes and he was I think he had like
an hour maybe a little bit less than an
hour but I thought I'm gonna go Knight
to b8 and next I'm gonna play Knight to
c6 and then I know he has a better
position but if I can play knight c6
maybe maybe push a6 and be 5 or
something then I thought maybe I could
hold this position but hereafter this
Knights to be a he mmediately played
Queen to b4 and here now when I saw this
Queen to be formal I saw that my queen
doesn't really have a doesn't really
have a good square to go to I didn't
want to I didn't want to allow any moves
like Queen to c6 then I'm just getting
in the way of all the attacks maybe 595
if I want to Queen to b6 he can still
exchange it and I do get the open a file
well the same I open a file but then he
has the B file for his rooks and I have
doubled B points here I didn't really
like that so I decided to trade Queen's
Queen captures he plays pawn captures
and here I played f6 and that was very
happy about this f6 move as I thought
okay I'm kind of disturbing the bishop
on each for he can't really go anywhere
he will have to go to g3 at some point
and I'm really locking this f3 Knight
out of the game here since now the
knight doesn't really have anywhere to
go he would have to think something else
like maybe Knight d2 to b3 and then to
c5 but I was I was gonna play b6 at some
point any
way so I wasn't really worried about
this so although I did manage to lock
his night out of the game he does have
this beautiful open C file for the rook
so I thought if I could maybe counter
that then maybe I could hold this
position he played a bishop to g3 rook
to c7 immediately isn't such a great
idea for white because I can push a six
prevent him from pushing b5 and next I
will play Knight to c6 locking this rock
out so he can't connect rooks and with
Bishop to f7 I will be with rook to f7 I
will be able to exchange this rook and
then maybe bring the other Brooke into
the game but here in sorry he played
better to g3 and now instead of going a
six first as as was my plan I decided to
go for another plan such such is the way
of chess I play Knight to c6 with the
idea of attacking the poem before I knew
that he would push it to b5 and then I
thought knife to a5 and b6 and okay he
that pushed b5 and I went went Knight to
a5 night the before is an interesting
move but in the end it definitely favors
white after he moves the bishop the only
way for me to prevent losing a piece
because after he pushes a 3-2 go is to
push a 5 and after he pushes a 3 E 4 and
now I created an outpost for the night
and e3 but he can just ignore this
capture and after I capture he can push
b6 and this is a much better position
for white after I block you can go row
k5 go rook a1 and push b5 next and white
is definitely breaking through here so
after this b5
I played Knight to a5 with the idea of
going b6 may be mash up the b7 finally
developed as if even if he pushes rook
to c7 then I can play Bishop to d7 as a
my knife from a5 will be guarding the
best repel I knew that it was a very
passive position but again you know I
don't mind holding the passive position
if I can so he played rook to c7 and I
played rook to F
now first offering in exchange of rooks
he played rook a to c1
I played rook captures rook captures and
now b6 which the idea of playing Bishop
to b7 so now as he doesn't really have a
useful move yet
I mean his bishop is very nice and III
he is dark square Bishop is beautiful
and g3 but this night isn't really doing
anything so he played knife to d2 trying
to activate it
I played Bishop to f8 as my bishop
wasn't really doing all that much on g7
I mean it was actually doing all that
much well my bishop wasn't g7 he's
actually preventing him from attacking
h7 point as he does have a bishop on d3
orokin c7 and he will push h4 and h5
trying to grab both of these points so
although my bishop isn't like really
acting when g7 it actually does have a
purpose but okay I tried to activate it
even more as I was passive for the
entire game I wanted some activity he
pushed h4 and I went a six here trying
to at least open up a DEA file for me he
played a four I played Punk at first I
played Bishop to b4 now forcing his
knight back
he played Knight back to f3 and here I
played pawn captures he played Bishop
captures and that really wasn't there
really wasn't neat to do this I mean
probably just playing passively with
Bishop to b7 and maybe trying some rope
to c8 ideas was much better for me and
perhaps which if I continue like this I
can maybe hold the position but I played
a captures he played Bishop captures and
here I was I was very long time I had
like I don't
probably like something like five
minutes or me before don't really
remember and here you can see that after
his bishop comes to b5 there's a really
no way to develop to develop for black
here if I play something like because
he's he's threatening Bishop to eh then
he has some checking radius here this
pawn will force the force its way to h5
exchange here and then create
a weakness on h7 so if I try to go back
Bishop to a faith to again put my bishop
on g7 then I'm like extremely passive he
can go Bishop e8 and after I block you
can go Bishop to d6 and now with his
bishops with his Bishop they're slicing
my position like this this would this
would be unplayable so after this Bishop
captures on b5 I played Bishop a6 hoping
either to exchange bishops or two maybe
activate my light square Bishop about
here I missed a crucial move
he simply played Bishop to d7 and here I
saw that there is no way for me to
defend the e6 pawn as it's such a
trivial mistake but I was considering so
many things I simply missed the obvious
one and you know the time pressure
didn't help of course if I defended with
King f7 he has this very nice discovery
grabbing my rockin a8 so here I probably
I could resign here but I tried a couple
more moves at least to try and create
some complications I played e5 he
captured and now I played Bishop to c4
with the idea of maybe somehow pushing
this and my light square Bishop will be
guarding my king he played Bishop d6
check I moved the king and now he put
captured on f6 I played Bishop to c3
simply not allowing his Bishop to come
to t5 to checkmate my king but here
unfortunately he has a checkmate in two
moves and feel free feel free to find it
it's it's not very complicated but it's
also very nice so I hope you did find it
even without pausing the video here he
played Knight to g5 and in this position
I resigned the game as there is no
defense against rook captures on h7 so
yeah I mean and I mean an interesting
game I felt you know I didn't feel that
bad about losing because you know I came
unprepared and since I'm like really
terrible at openings you know I was
pretty satisfied with my game
this bishop to a sex move was the first
big mistake of the game
I'll move 25 so not a bad not a bad
thing for me but you know like I said
even even if up to this point there were
there were no moves that could be
classified as mistakes playing passively
like was was the biggest mistake I
probably could have done as you know
it's simply better to maybe I managed
imitator to maintain material equality
throughout the entire game up until this
mistake but you know it cost me so much
activity that there's there was really
nothing I could do so even this you know
mere control of the C file was was like
he was up peace so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and maybe
learned something from it you know don't
play passively play actively as if you
play passively then you will maybe have
one good move to play I play actively
then you will have a variety of moves
that can create complications for our
point so yeah yeah I do hope you enjoyed
it and I would like to thank cycling
channel Gary Carpentier and Mac Matt
back with sorry yeah back with for a
contribution to my channel think a lot I
really appreciate it
as usually project to my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon with my second game from
this championship so thank you all and I
will see you soon